Speaker 1: Shocking new 24 Republican primary poll
shows Trump imploding. DeSantis at 56, Trump at
33. This is stunning stuff. BBC Article Trump's
Conservative Base Deserting Him For DeSantis.
Most Republican leaning voters would prefer
Florida's governor over Donald Trump as their
2024 presidential nominee, according to a survey
by a 56 to 33 margin. Dear God. Conservative
voters picked Ron DeSantis over Trump. The Suffolk
University USA Today poll also found Joe Biden
has a higher approval than Donald Trump. It
follows mixed results, I'll say, for Trump
back candidates in midterm elections. DeSantis out
polls Trump not only among the general electorate,
but also among these Republican leaning voters
who have been the former president's base.
Republicans and conservative independents
increasingly want Trumpism without Trump.
Also interesting, the poll released Tuesday
recorded only a 30% approval for Trump,
compared with 46 for Biden. The survey also found
over 60% of voters would prefer neither Trump nor
Biden stand in the 2024 race. So let's talk
through a few aspects of this first question,
which we should all be asking How
valuable is a presidential primary poll?
Roughly 18 or 19 months before the bulk of that
primary. We're 23 months from the 2024 election.
But these are primary polls. So we're dealing with
something that will take place over that summer.
So it's more like 19 months away. How valuable
is it a poll today? It's limited. It's quite
limited. The general answer is 19 months out.
Can't predict how the political landscape will
change between now and then. Things can happen
external to the candidates that shift support
one way or the other. The economy may change. We
don't yet officially know that Joe Biden is even
running. DeSantis hasn't actually said he's
running. We don't know legally what is coming
for Donald Trump. International events, shifts
in public opinion scandals. We just don't know.
There's all of these things that make this polling
extraordinarily premature. That being said, the
most important takeaway here is zoom out. Trump
has been the president and is the de facto leader
of the Republican Party. Ron DeSantis isn't even
running. And here is a good poll, a good pollster
that says the Santos is up more than 20 points
over Trump among the primary electorate. That's
not the type of thing you can easily dismiss, at
least as far as pointing to the picture today.
Now, what about Trump? What is he doing or saying
about this? Trump posted an alternative poll to
troth central interactive polls i a polls 2022
Politico Morning Consult which has Trump winning
by 18. So there are definitely other polls
out there that are not bad for Donald Trump.
At what point does a presidential primary poll?
Accurately reflect who's likely to be the eventual
winner. In the months leading up to the primary.
You know, but polling can fluctuate, particularly
in a very contested primary with many candidates.
The polling can fluctuate April, May and then
typically June, July of the election year. I'm
not even talking about 23. I'm talking about
24. June. July is when it really starts to
become definitive. And so these are very important
early signals, what they really mean about what
will take place in a year and a half, we really
don't know. But if you're Trump, you'd rather
be winning as the former president than losing
to a guy who hasn't even said that he's running